dans le cabot d'elgado monter Pez
bienvenue dans la plus grande mine de
rubis au monde
de nationalité indienne paroi car est
ingénieur en chef il est là depuis les
débuts de l'extraction sur le site il y
a 10 ans
aujourd'hui la mine fournit plus de la
moitié du marché mondial une
cinquantaine de tonnes par an
cet endroit est incroyable tout a
commencé quand on a ouvert en 2012
on est parti de rien
on sera au Puy de et puis après au 3
bonjour
[Musique]
les schémas ne sont jamais arrivés
jusqu'ici
des dizaines de kilomètres de pistes sur
une terre rouge
une immense mine à ciel ouvert une
concession de plus de 33000 hectares 3
fois la superficie de Paris
comme Rajesh 1600 employés s'activent
pour extraire la richesse locale
soyez
vous pouvez voir ici ces pierres
il y a aussi des rubis qui ne sont pas
incrustés dedans mais qui se trouvent
dans la terre
et bien nous on prend 50 cm au-dessus et
pareil en dessous donc vous prenez tout
pour ne rien manquer
pour ne pas passer à côté d'une seule
pierre précieuse tout est passé au
crible fin
chaque jour des centaines de tonnes de
terre sont prélevées et vont être soumis
à un long process
à chaque étape nouveau contrôle de
sécurité et rageaient pas
tout le monde doit-on passer par là même
le grand patron
oui nous sommes dans la zone de lavage
c'est ici que ça se passe
à partir d'ici les tonnes de terre sont
lavées à grandes eaux
un premier tri pour récupérer la roche
et en bout de chaîne au fil des
calibrages les rubis finissent par
apparaître
pour les approcher il faut encore
montrer pas de blanche
vous voyez ma veste a des poches cousues
c'est comme si elle n'en avait pas un
spécialement faite pour ici
et vous avez dû changer de chaussures
aussi
j'ai déjà enlevé mes chaussures et je
porte maintenant des tongs
le trésor est à l'abri derrière cette
porte blindée
un dernier SAS pour entrer dans le saint
des saints
des allures de laboratoire ici fini les
engins mécaniques tout se passe
désormais à l'oeil et à la main
ces pépites écarlates sont sous la
responsabilité d'Edward il est
sud-africain
sa mission superviser le classement des
rubis en fonction de leurs qualités la
taille de la pierre sa forme sa clarté
et sa couleur
est
occupé à classer les pierres
c'est grâce à ce tri qu'on trouve les
pièces les plus précieuses
c'est quasiment prêt à l'exportation
avant de le faire on fait venir des
officiels du gouvernement les douanes
qui nous valide tout ça et une fois
qu'on a toutes les autorisations
nécessaires on est prêt à exporter
sur cette table je ne sais pas je
pourrais pas vous dire il y en aurait
pour combien
c'est difficile à dire tout est mélangé
on parle de millions de dollars non non
quand même pas quand même pas
edward ne nous en dira pas davantage sur
le prix mais aujourd'hui le cours du
rubis flambe la pierre rouge est très
prisée en Asie
pour ages l'ingénieur en chef tous les
efforts de la mine sont largement
récompensés
[Musique]
tout se procès depuis l'exploration
minière le lavage le triage jusqu'au
produit final
tout ça c'est très satisfaisant pour
tous ceux qui travaillent ici
c'est un travail d'équipe et je suis
très heureux d'y participer c'est très
excitant
[Musique]
encore une autre étape de sécurité à
respecter il ne doit rien avoir de
cacher dans mes mains
en disant James fiels le groupe
britannique qui détient la mine a vendu
pour plus de 500 millions d'euros de
joyaux rouges dans le monde
une fortune entachée de polémique au
Mozambique on est allé jusqu'à évoquer
le scandale des rubis de sang
la mine de montée se trouve dans l'une
des régions les plus pauvres du pays
à la découverte du filon de rubis s'en
est suivi une ruée vers l'or rouge
venue de tout le Mozambique et même des
pays voisins des milliers de personnes
sont venues tenter leur chance
James alors fait régner sa loi 7000
mineurs illégaux ont été expulsés par
des compagnies de sécurité privée ou la
police locale
les méthodes contre les mineurs
clandestins sont brutales comme le
montrent cette vidéo relayée par des
militants de défense des droits de
l'homme
accuser d'exaction et même de meurtre la
compagnie a accepté en 2019 de payer
près de 7 millions d'euros pour étouffer
une plainte collective
aujourd'hui la mine tente de redorer son
image auprès des communautés locales lui
aussi indien pralatte oumarcing en est
le directeur
elles ont l'air bonne c'est tomates il
supervise les projets sociaux de sa
compagnie un bienfaiteur salué par les
paysans du village
[Musique]
soit ici nous trouvons ça très bien ce
sont eux qui nous aident de plus en plus
il nous fournissent les engrais les
produits chimiques et aussi les
tracteurs
tout provient de la mine de rugby
nous on trouve ça vraiment très bien
cette village se trouve sur la
concession de la mine avec ses
différentes initiatives la compagnie
fait tout pour se concilier les bonnes
grâces des habitants
mais malgré tout la misère dans la
région est encore là et le rubis fait
toujours rêver d'un avenir meilleur
il y a beaucoup de mineurs illégaux vous
en trouverez partout
même dans ce village
l'extraction minière illégale est un
problème majeur pour nous
une fois qu'on les trouve on se doit de
respecter la charte du respect des
droits de l'homme des Nations unies
qu'on a signé
quand nous arrêtons les mineurs illégaux
nous les remettons immédiatement à la
police locale
derrière le discours les temps ont-ils
vraiment changé
qu'elle est aujourd'hui le sort réservé
aux mineurs illégaux
[Musique]
le lendemain il est 5h du matin à
quelques kilomètres de la mine nous
avons rendez-vous avec un groupe de
mineurs clandestins
il s'apprête à braver l'interdiction de
creuser dans les terres appartenant à la
compagnie
on va travailler on va creuser
pourquoi vous partez si tôt
parce qu'on a peur des gardes de la mine
il y a moins de risques tôt le matin
il leur faute une dizaine de minutes de
marche avant d'arriver sur un site
repéré à l'avance
ici autour de ce plan d'eau
arrivée sur place pas de temps à perdre
ils opère le plus vite possible avec un
équipement rudimentaire
ça prend beaucoup trop de temps
c'est très difficile on peut creuser
ramener 20 30 40 voire sans sacs et au
final ne rien retirer
toujours au pas de course une fois les
sacs chargés le groupe de mineurs
clandestins lave la terre à sa façon
un filtrage sommaire un système D pour
ne garder que des pierres
[Musique]
et enfin un premier tri pour espérer
tomber sur un rubis
dépêchez-vous
les acheteurs ils nous vole
nous on ne connaît pas les prix combien
c'est un gramme on n'en sait rien alors
on leur va au prix qu'il nous fixe
et aujourd'hui encore ils ont toujours
très peur des gardes de la compagnie
mieux vaut pour eux ne pas se faire
prendre
il nous arrache notre matériel et
ensuite ils nous mettent en prison
on a peur mais comme on est très pauvre
même si on va voir la compagnie minière
il ne nous donne pas de travail
alors on est obligé de venir voler ici
15 minutes chrono les mineurs et des
goûts repartent avec leur maigre butin
ils affineront le tri des sacs dans leur
village avec la faible chance de
décrocher le gros lot